foreign
here and welcome to real estate the
Ramsay way in this episode we're talking
about the true cost of buying a home
because if you want to make that new
home you're dreaming of an actual
reality you need accurate expectations
of the whole home buying situation and
what it'll cost you so stick around
figure out how much house you can really
afford Nathan's with us in Pensacola hi
Nathan welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave a long time listener I
appreciate your show and uh definitely
live by almost all the advice you have
well thank you how can I help
um so
um my wife and I
um are looking at possibly buying a
property it's a little bit more
expensive than what I'm used to buying
so um right now we own a home and we're
just trying to figure out if it makes
sense to take our our current
Investments and just basically liquidate
our current Investments and then now uh
go into debt with a mortgage that would
be probably about a 300 000 mortgage
after we're done with liquidating all of
our expenses and all of our debt I'm
sorry all of our uh assets
okay how old are you
so 47 47 and 46. all of your assets you
mean you're pulling retirement out
no no no
um the retirement I can't touch until uh
later but we've got um uh listening to
you guys on like uh smartvestor kind of
stuff and uh we went with uh a smart
investor Pro here in Pennsylvania
how much money in Investments that are
non-retirement
um probably about uh 600k total okay
and your current residence has how much
equity in it
it's about 400 okay so you're buying a
million three house
[Music]
would be a little bit less
okay I missed how you get 300 000 in
debt because I got a million dollars
here 600 and 400.
[Music]
so I guess uh the mortgage might not be
quite 300 dead um it'll be probably
closer to 200. when we uh when you have
all the closing costs and everything
into it
okay so you're talking about you're not
going to net 400 out of your house
well we should we should net 400 out of
the house and you have 600 in
Investments
and savings and everything yes that's a
million and the house is a million
there's not two hundred thousand dollars
in closing costs there's not a 20
closing cost there's no such thing
so I guess it's just
it's just good feeling going with a
higher home value and I guess the
biggest that I have is it doesn't make
sense to liquidate the uh the
Investments that we have right now I
wouldn't buy the house if I didn't
because you're going to go into debt so
it's the same question of if I had a
paid four million dollar house would I
go borrow 600 000 on it to put money
into Investments no I wouldn't not
taking the money out of the Investments
and putting them on the house is the
same thing as borrowing on your house to
do that so you should not buy the house
unless you're willing to use the
Investments to do it what's your
household income
um right now it's probably about 1 10.
and how old are you guys
48 or 46.
will you be able to afford the taxes on
a million dollar property at a with a
hundred thousand dollars a year just to
just to maintain the property keep the
lights on this thing keep the yard mode
uh yes we will
yeah um Florida's got some generous uh
disabled veterans uh tax benefits okay
so why why do you want to buy a million
dollar property
it's it's something my wife and I have
always dreamed about living on water and
uh this is an opportunity to do so right
now
okay
I don't think you're going to need a
mortgage or if you do it's a very very
small one and you're going to turn
around and get that paid off as fast as
you can if you're sitting in this
property debt free
uh within a couple of years then I'm
fine with this idea if you want to do it
um it the the thing that's out of
balance that you're feeling is is that
the vast majority of your net worth is
now tied up in your single family home
that does not that does not generate an
income
it does grow in value but it does not
generate an income and so
um you know you're gonna have to really
pour on the coals and build some
Investments by the fact that you don't
have any house payment in the near
future to make this work but no you
don't need a 300 000 mortgage the
numbers you keep giving me that you act
like they add up and they don't add up
I mean 600 and 400 is 1 million and you
buy a million dollar house for a million
dollars and you use a million dollars
you shouldn't have a mortgage
um and so this makes me uncomfortable
like it makes me uneasy that's a lot of
the reason is that all everything you
own is going into this house except your
retirement well and uh it is it's out of
balance it's too much really uh but if
you're paying cash for it I think you
can tolerate it as long as you turn
around and start dumping money into
retirement really really quick uh would
I do this if I were in your shoes no I
wouldn't yeah
no I wouldn't maybe that's what I
wouldn't either because I don't want
that much of my net worth making a
hundred and ten thousand dollars tied up
in a single family house that does not
create income and I'm thinking of it if
the air conditioner goes out on this
million dollar house it's going to be an
expensive repair or if the driveway
needs to be or if I got to do some
Plumbing work it's all so expensive
everything I mean just 100 of the houses
break yeah yeah 100 of them need crap
done to them and um brand new no matter
who built them no matter where they are
I mean I'm a lot of real estate and
there's just uh they they eat money yeah
so you're put to your point that's good
yeah I think I I you know the more I sit
there and talk this through and
listening to John too
I'm risk averse though so let me say
that a lot but I mean I
there's just no margin here there's no
there's no way I can't come back to
margins there's no wiggle there's no
wiggle room what if you get sick I
wonder if you get something life goes
sideways or not now you got a lot of
wiggle room with 600 000 in the bank so
probably what I would do is take your
600 and pay off your current residence
uh which you should have done anyway if
you're listening to me but that's that
part where you said you just did part of
what I teach I remember that part I
didn't drive by it I heard it and
um then then I would save like a crazy
person and I might do this deal in five
years where I've got 500 000 left over
after I buy it now that started if you
had 500 000 left over non-retirement
after you move in there you do a million
dollar house 110 000 incomes is low for
a million dollar house but if you're
paying cash for it for whatever reason
it's okay but you do need some liquidity
and it doesn't need to be
freaking 90 of your net worth that's
just that's out of balance or can you
save up some money and and go
multiple weeks instead of lake house a
year and I mean Phoenix I don't even
mind if you buy you know if your dreams
live on the water I agree I like living
on the water I've got I've got
properties on the water I like it but um
water's amazing yeah but the uh but but
it's not amazing if it steals your piece
instead it gives you pictures yeah so
and then no margin here no margin it's
dangerous that's a dangerous deal no I
wouldn't do it I'm gonna retract I
wouldn't do it because I don't like the
fact there's no wiggle room what I would
do is I pay off my house today and I'd
start saving like a crazy person and
make this a three to a five year dream
and just keep piling up cash and keep
investing with a paid for house but
you're gonna do what you're going to do
because you already don't do some of the
stuff we teach so that's up to you you
get to decide but that's
that's what I would do if I woke up in
your shoes
um I find people don't have margin with
their time they don't have it with their
relationships they don't have it with
work they don't have it with money we
just have a margin free Society now man
well they just it
um there's friction it greats to get
Frayed Ends yeah and you get frayed at
the ends and it's just um because
everything's pushed to the edge and it
takes what would have normally been a
blessing and and you you know you add
two doses of stress to it and all of a
sudden you don't the thing you're
supposed to be in love with you hate and
when you think of it uh psychologically
our brains were designed to to run at
that level when a lion was chasing us
not to live like that yeah it just
rattles everything to our core you know
it's a big old house with a lion chasing
you around inside you just parked a line
in the front yard yeah that's right
Andrea starts off this hour in Dallas
Texas hey Andrea welcome to the Ramsey
Show
oh Dave it's good to talk to you again
you too thank you for having me on your
show well thank you
I don't know you probably I don't know
if you remember I actually met you back
in 2019 at your studio my husband and I
stopped by and I I I'm a balloon artist
I made a bunch of balloons for your
grandkids oh thank you thank you I'm
sorry I've met so many people I can't
remember my name so but I'm glad you're
here how can we help
okay I was hoping you could help me with
a little disagreement I'm having with my
husband
um
we've been married 10 years and I have
listened to you longer and got him on to
the uh
The Total Money Makeover we followed you
and were able to get debt free good and
we like it he likes it a lot and but now
we are having
um our second baby due in November and
he's having to work from home and I'm
nesting and we feel like it's time to
move up in house and we have a little
bit of a disagreement I feel like I
found like the ideal dream house and he
feels like it's too much and
um it would it would cause us to have a
mortgage again for a little while and he
just he just doesn't want to do that and
I'm just like
don't feel like I want to settle when
we're going to be in the house hopefully
a long time so
um that's okay so what is your current
home worth
um we are hoping after realtor fees that
we can get about three hundred thousand
dollars out of it um and what would the
other house cost
[Music]
so a move of two hundred thousand do you
have any money saved above the 300 we do
we've got our emergency fund of 16 Grand
which we're not going to touch correct
and then in other various accounts we've
managed to save up about
a little over a hundred grand okay so
you're only a hundred thousand dollars
in disagreement
basically yeah if you had another 100K
would he be okay with the 500 000 house
he he would be thrilled with it his
thing
his thing it's not too much house it's
no doubt that he was
right it's not too much house it's a no
debt he says this house is fancy it's a
want it's not a need we shouldn't go
into debt for a want okay and um okay I
I yeah I got it I got it and so what's
your household income
so so 2021 we
went one week how quickly can you save
100 grand
um I don't know
um we
I mean if we less than three years
probably
two to three years two and a half years
maybe two to three years
you had to do it to save your life you
could save 100 Grand in two years but
three you could definitely do it
okay because you'd be living on beans
and rice again in order to hit this goal
to do two years
three years you can definitely do it
okay or you can pick up do you have
anything else you can sell
oh not nothing that's like worth much I
mean yeah you got expensive cars
no they're they're used cars and they
are paid off and they're you know kind
of old and okay they're not expensive
okay what about going to a 400 000 house
and you can pay cash for it have you
looked into what that would look like um
we've we've um we're still looking and
keeping our eyes open we haven't ruled
it out
um
okay so here's the deal what we're
really arguing about is not whether you
have too much house if of understanding
your outline what you're really arguing
about is the 100 is whether we go in
debt or not
right and your husband's going I finally
got free I can't walk willingly into
another bear trap I can't do it I can't
I can't swallow the pill as much as I
love you as much as I want you to have
what you want I just can't go back there
it makes me throw up into my mouth
is also like inflation is going up and
what if I buy too much house and then
like
crazy and then I can't like no you don't
have to worry about that you don't worry
about that what you've got to worry
about is what you can control
your bottom line is you guys are arguing
about a hundred grand in two to three
years
that's what you're arguing about you're
not really arguing about whether to move
if moving is valid whether the 500 000
house is too big a house uh whether
we're really not arguing about any of
those things we're just 100 Grand short
of doing what you want to do and you're
willing to go in debt and he's not
correct that's what it comes down to and
so once you quantify it that way it
gives you some real good points for
discussion
um I don't think either one of you are
in the stupid Zone with this if you took
out a little mortgage and paid it off
real fast it doesn't violate our
guidelines but I've got to personally
agree with your husband once I got out
of debt you weren't gonna drag me back
in kicking screaming under any
circumstances there wasn't anything
Sharon wanted bad enough for me to do
that or I wanted bad enough for me to do
that ever
and I was actually more likely to want
something than she was but you couldn't
get me to do it again so I kind of
understand where your husband's coming
from I don't think George and I have an
answer for there's no one right or wrong
here you guys have to get on the same
page of whatever you do going forward
and I don't think you're buying this
house unless you both come into
agreement that's for sure
here's a dose of reality for you
drowning in a house payment every month
is what's called being house poor and it
means you won't have enough money for
your other financial goals but here's
some good news you don't need a degree
in economics to figure out what your
house payment should cost just check out
our free mortgage calculator to get a
clear idea of what your monthly payment
should look like go to
ramseysolutions.com mortgage calculator
or click the link in the show notes to
start crunching the numbers
Brett is with us in Provo Utah hi Brett
welcome to the Ramsay show
oh thanks Dave thanks for having me on
sure what's up
uh so me and my family we have been
renting for the last year while paying
off student loans uh we paid off 115 000
of student loans it's awesome yeah
thank you
um yeah so we're at a point now where
we're looking uh to save up for a down
payment on a house
um
and the house we would be looking to buy
it would take us about three years to to
get a down payment for that house but
we're wondering if maybe it might just
be smarter to wait another three years
so a total of six years to pay for a
house in cash
how much of a down payment are you doing
in three years 50 percent
yeah it's pretty much close to that yeah
houses are how did you determine fifty
percent as a down payment
uh just for the house we were looking at
for no I'm saying 100 000 and you you
said you can do 50 percent
of the house price in three years right
yes
four hundred thousand
uh three yeah I guess 350 is what I was
looking at yeah okay and what do you
make
uh 260. way to go good for you how old
are you gosh
uh I'm 32 and my wife is 29.
okay well this is one of the uh maybe
the only answer
that I ever give here on the air that is
um
not what I would do
but what is okay to do okay what I do
the way I live my life for the last 30
plus years now since I went broke is I
don't borrow money
period for anything
ever
and so I have to
figure out a way to cash flow it because
there is nothing that I want badly
enough or that I'm scared enough of to
go in debt for it I have been there done
that I didn't like the T-shirt I'm not
doing it any more okay I truly do
believe that the Bible is telling the
truth that the borrowers slave to the
lender and I truly don't borrow money
and I do believe that that is the
shortest path
to wealth
by the way okay uh the the starting few
years is rough
but the the ending years are amazing
so uh uh uh now having said all of that
then it's the only advice we give here
on the air that I don't personally
follow and that is if you take out a
mortgage with a good strong down payment
50 is more than a good strong a good
strong down payment would be 10 or 15 or
something like that 20 would avoid PMI
that's good and your payment on a
15-year fix is no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay if you did that in
your case
you could then pay that house off within
six years
right right and if you could pay cash
for it in six years you could pay it off
in six years and obviously anyone who
pays their home off in six years is way
weird compared to the culture
so you're you're weird no matter where
we are on the Spectrum yeah and you're
and you're heading in the in the you
know your your face is under the column
of smart people no matter what we do on
this spectrum that's right so either one
of those is fine so it's just a matter
of
someone call me a legalist some would
call me a purist uh someone just call me
not a hypocrite but um but that I don't
borrow so you can do either by Ramsay
guidelines anywhere in between those two
things and be there so you could put
down 50 you could put down eighty
percent you could put down 20 on a
15-year fix where the payment's no more
than a fourth year take on paying it
wouldn't be in this case and then turn
it paid off as fast as you can all of
that is within our guidelines because we
know that that's going to lead you to
wealth Brett how old are you
what do you do for a living
so I'm a nurse anesthetist ah good very
good you're killing him so yeah that was
where I was kind of having the the
question between the two just because is
it is there any measure on if it's
harder for kids to move when they're
older that was kind of what we were
going between two I mean I wouldn't want
to wait I wouldn't want to move in high
school if that's what you're asking I
think that kids are very resilient I
think that by the time they you know
once they put down Roots if you get into
those high school years it can be a
little bit tough but I mean you can
recover from anything but yeah when
they're how you have you've got kids now
how
so the oldest is seven so seven five and
three seven they're all right she would
be
13 you know if we waited the full six
years to to pay well that's also
assuming you get absolutely no increases
in income right
right
yeah yeah I yeah true it's a good point
which is weird because when I start
saving towards something that I want
really bad what I'll do is work my butt
off
yeah and my income goes up and you know
I'm able to just attack it and so my
guess is that it won't take you as long
as the math on a straight line without
any increases in Pay says
okay that you should have because your
intensity will go up and your income
will probably go up both during this
time so it'll probably be four or five
years but same thing's true of paying
the house off
yeah yeah if you bought it and we're
living in it so uh we're not going to
yell at you for either one
um uh uh
I just love the options that you're
looking at I love that you're calling in
here talking about 50 down or 100 down
that's a wonderful quandary to be in
you've got options you've got your head
in the right place that's for sure and
so again I
truly do believe these principles and so
I truly believe that if I live them I'm
going to be the safest
in the event of a pandemic I'm sitting
in a building that's worth
I don't know what's this thing worth now
three 400 3 400 million dollars and paid
for and it's paid for and so nobody I
didn't have to worry during the pandemic
that we couldn't make the payments here
yeah okay is that allows this bald head
to lay on a pillow and sleep
you know it just is a different world
Christine is with us in Cheyenne Wyoming
hi Christine how are you
great how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up
um thank you so much for taking my call
so my husband and I are new listeners of
yours and
um we're on baby steps four five and six
we have no debt except for our mortgage
good but we're concerned that our
mortgage is a bit High
um it doesn't quite follow your ratios
so I just wanted to talk that through
with you and see us we should just keep
going on or make a change
okay in this case our ratios uh
don't matter as much in the case of a
mortgage payment as a percentage of your
income as why
we have the ratios now that matters a
lot okay the why is simply uh if you use
up all your money on your house payment
you don't have any money it's called
House poor
right
and that will cause you with if you're
living with a super high house payment
even though you're already out of debt
and your baby step four five and six
it'll keep you from investing long term
keep you from your generosity goals
um and it in some cases if it's super
high if for people people feel forced uh
to take a car payment because they don't
save up for a car because I don't have
any room to save up for a car or
something like that so that's the reason
we tell people to not get a super high
house payment like most of the culture
tells you to do that and so once you
can't understand that then you can kind
of back into your particulars
and say you know okay what do we what
are we violating on the 25 of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fixed and um
and how is that going to be okay given
that we don't want to be house poor so
how much is your house payment
say again
3 900.
and your monthly take-home pay is
eleven thousand
okay so you're about 34 percent
right okay and um
what do you guys do for a living
uh my
is what and
he's
apply home with our kids
supply chain oh God I can't hear okay
um supply chain
all right and uh
he's killing it
um
so
how many raises now because last two
years don't count what do you guys feel
like the trajectory of his income is
is it going to go up substantially in
the next three years
I think so which makes this conversation
not needed moot right
okay yeah because I mean if it goes from
33 to 28 to 25 with three raises because
your house payment stays the same your
income goes up then we're not worried
about you being house poor long term
correct
correct yeah so that that's one fix for
this but if you had two wild years based
on supply chain backup and he crushed it
and he's going to settle back into 9 000
a month now you got a problem exactly
so what are you looking at on his income
do you think
I think it'll go out
it goes down if it goes down you need to
reevaluate this house
okay if it goes as long as it is has an
upward trajectory in the next 36 to 48
months you're not going to be stuck
there with all your money going to a
house payment and not being able to fund
your kids college fund
or having an air conditioner break and
you got to get it go to a credit union
to get to be able to pay for it right
so just don't get yourself to where
you're there that's the whole point of
the thing you see uh and yeah so you
don't you don't need Ramsay to tell you
how to manage your life you just but you
but A good rule period whether Ramsay's
in your discussion or not is don't be
house poor don't have a house payment
that takes up all your money makes you
broke and so uh but I think you sound
like you're okay it's not ideal if you
were getting ready to buy a home I would
tell you to back off don't be so house
uh you know but you're there I wouldn't
tell you to move over this you're not
trapped and hopelessly
mathematically disabled you know
so I wouldn't tell you to do that but uh
but you don't have any room it's got to
go up it can't go back and you don't
have any wiggle room because if it gets
if it goes down much it stays down very
long you're going to be forced into a
different property but right now I think
you got a lot of house and in Cheyenne
Wyoming it's a big freaking house
that's a big dog right there well done
good for you I bet it's fun
listen I know some of you are thinking
that buying a home the way we teach is
next to Impossible with home prices
where they are right now but that's why
my best advice is patience don't give in
to the temptation to stretch your
dollars and buy a home that's out of
your price range it's just not worth
sacrificing your other financial goals
like your retirement your kids college
just be a grown-up about it and be
patient thanks for listening today share
this with your friends and family who
you think will enjoy it and be on the
lookout for our next episode all about
navigating this crazy real estate market